allora alla periferia della mobilità
umana
e
condurvi con me in un viaggio che
vedrà alcune tappe in giro per il mondo
partiamo parlando di periferie di
mobilità umana partiamo da questa questa
fotografia e il the cats e river è un
fiume dove oggi si muore
da una parte ci sono i campi profughi in
eritrea siamo siamo in etiopica vi farò
fughi che ospitano rifugiati eritrei
fuga da una dittatura e dall'altra ci
sono i passeur che li aspettano per
aiutarli a proseguire il viaggio a fare
attraversare il deserto e poi il mare in
questo fiume dicevo si muore oggi
mangiate dai coccodrilli o perché
trasportati dalla corrente e in qualche
modo questo confine rappresenta la
periferia quello che di vederla
periferia dal centro parlando di
mobilità umana in avanti quello in basso
ok perfetto non può passare non può non
passare però il nostro viaggio
dall'europa domani domani si vota in
particolare perché ve lo faccio vedere
con questi con questi numeri la
principale preoccupazione oggi per i
cittadini europei è rappresentata dalle
migrazioni più del terrorismo più della
situazione economica più della
situazione sociale in europa
il tema che ha governato anche questa
campagna elettorale è stata in tutti i
paesi europei quello della migrazione
nonostante non siamo più in una crisi
come qualche come qualche anno fa e come
ha risposto l'europa a queste
preoccupazioni crescenti dovute anche al
bombardamento mediatico che
quotidianamente abbiamo ce lo dice
l'osservatorio di pavia sui media l'anno
scorso oltre 4.000 notizie nei
principali tg italiani sul tema delle
migrazioni in particolare parlando di
sbarchi di sicurezza che quindi hanno
condizionato la nostra visione rispetto
a questo tema di cittadini europei e che
condizionano anche chi ci governa nella
costruzione questi sono i primi muri
belen club di melilla e in spagna che
divide la spagna dal dal marocco e poi
la grecia e la turchia sul fiume evros
che ci dividono dall'oriente la bulgaria
con la barriera con con la turchia e tra
l'ungheria e la serbia
quali sono le conseguenze di questa
fortezza europa che si sta costruendo
che pian piano stiamo costruendo in in
europa non passiamo dalla libia in
questo viaggio perché la libia è
qualcosa di cui tutti i giorni sentiamo
parlare di barconi di persone che
arrivano
ma passiamo dall'est europa da via c in
particolare oggi si calcola che sulla
rotta balcanica ci sono circa 100mila
persone in situazione di accampamento
via c'è un piccolo campo profughi
così chiamato sono tende dove la gente
sta campata al nord della bosnia confine
con la croazia nel tentativo di passare
quella frontiera oppure un'altra
immagine in cui non siamo abituati a
vedere nei confini all'interno degli
aeroporti di bambini che per raggiungere
le loro madri sono costretti
illegalmente a nascondersi dentro le
valigie come fossero dei parchi per
poter attraversare una frontiera è lo
slogan che siamo abituati a sentire che
ci ha richiamato da tempo e chiudere i
porti chiudere l'arrivo chiudere le
frontiere e non siamo però soli in
questa battaglia contro le persone
contro i migranti
siamo in buona o cattiva compagnia
allargando lo sguardo questo è playa de
tijuana si confine tra stati uniti e
messico dove stanno costruendo il muro
da qualche anno che addirittura finisce
nell'oceano per impedire alle persone di
attraversare quella quella frontiera e
che però sollevato una serie di
preoccupazioni anche all'interno della
comunità americana bella leggo questa
citazione perché interessante nel
contesto di un ted perché viene dalla
questa diciamo piccola resistenza viene
dai giganti della gig economy quelli che
si sono anche inventati pet talks negli
negli stati uniti che hanno scritto nel
2017 una lettera trump che dice così fin
dalla nascita del paese gli stati uniti
d'america sono stati la terra delle
opportunità accogliendo i nuovi arrivati
e dando loro la possibilità di costruire
famiglie carriere e imprese
siamo una nazione resa più forte dagli
immigrati come imprenditori e leader
aziendali
la nostra capacità di far crescere le
nostre aziende e creare posti di lavoro
dipende dal contributo dei migranti di
ogni provenienza e in qualche modo
questo risponde a una visione di società
aperta che che però fa si scontra
diciamo con le immagini che in giro per
il mondo proseguendo il nostro viaggio
siamo abituati a vedere di profonda
estrema disuguaglianza tra una parte e
l'altra rappresentante nelle grossi
nelle grosse capitali del mondo città
del capo
città del messico los angeles con la
skyline ma anche sotto la street view di
persone che dormono che dormono per
strada bombe con le norme baraccopoli ai
confini della della città una e robbie
la questione che stanno da una parte
della barricata la cosa più semplice
costruire muri fermare i barconi fermare
le persone interrogarsi però cosa cosa
avremmo fatto se fossimo nati dall'altra
parte del muro dall'altra parte del
della barricata perché in fondo alla
fine nessuna decide dove dove nascere e
non solo però barriere fisiche vengono
costruite ci sono i confini con fini che
per la maggior parte dei paesi africani
non vogliono dire praticamente nulla
sono linee tracciate da noi bianchi
occidentali alla fine della
decolonizzazione che però non hanno
nessun significato le persone attraverso
una con una libertà di circolazione
molto forte per diverse zone dell'africa
ma anche barriere amministrative e
burocratiche questa qui è la classifica
della potenza dei passaporti nel mondo
noi col nostro passaporto bordo
occidentale stiamo in cima alla
classifica molto ben piazzati al terzo
posto possiamo entrare in 187 paesi al
mondo senza visto col visto all'ingresso
pagando pochissimo insieme in buona
compagnia di tutti i paesi occidentali o
quasi tutti in fondo alla classifica ci
stanno persone che non possono muoversi
così liberamente come come noi possiamo
fare e che sono per lo più le
nazionalità di provenienza dei dei
rifugiati di chi scappa da situazioni
che è costretto a rifugiarsi in un altro
stato ea muoversi per salvarsi la vita
di chi stiamo parlando
sono circa 68 milioni di persone al
mondo i cosiddetti migranti forzati cioè
le persone che sono costrette a muoversi
per ragioni esterne alla propria volontà
da casa loro per guerre per dittatore
per persecuzioni personali oltre la metà
40 milioni di loro stanno dentro i
confini nazionali non si muovono e chi
si muove oltre confini nazionali che
supera il confine per la maggior parte
rimane appena al di là dei confini nei
cosiddetti paesi in via di sviluppo che
ne ospitano la maggior parte però
parlare di numeri
mi rendo conto anche che non serve non
vuol dire non vuol dire molto allora vi
racconto la storia vi faccio vedere
questo video se puoi farlo partire dal
il puntatore non funziona queste sono le
se parte queste si sono le olimpiadi di
pechino del 2008
la batteria sono le qualificazioni la
batteria dei 200 metri non ci interessa
che vince la giamaicana solita ci
interessa però sapere la storia di
quella ragazza che sta in fondo samia il
suo mar una ragazza somala la miglior
atleta del suo paese la migliore atleta
sul mezzo fondo di tutto il corno
d'africa di allora quella che arriva
adesso che si vede sullo sfondo che
aveva il tempo per andare alle olimpiadi
di pechino non si è qualificata come
avete visto quelle sono le
qualificazioni non è arrivata alle
finali quindi non abbiamo conosciuta noi
pubblico che guardiamo solo l'ultimo
pezzo della storia
samia che ha rappresentato tantissimo
per il suo paese perché ha corso senza
il velo negli anni in cui c'era una
forte repressione all'interno del paese
aveva ancora il tempo nel 2012 quattro
anni dopo per andare alle olimpiadi di
londra
ma non aveva il passaporto visto e
quindi si è messa in mano a trafficanti
attraversato il sudan arrivata in libia
ed è morta nel mar mediterraneo per
andare a correre alle olimpiadi di
londra che non abbiamo mai visto insieme
a lei tantissime altre persone oltre
40.000 sono morte in questi anni i morti
certificati nel mar mediterraneo la
frontiera più pericolosa al mondo
questa è una foto scattata che ho
scattato nel cimitero di armo a reggio
calabria prosegue il nostro viaggio dove
sono sepolti diversi migranti vittime di
stragi appunto nel mediterraneo quella
scritta sconosciuto ignoto non abbiamo
dato mai un nome un volto a queste
persone vittime nella frontiera che non
potranno mai raccontare in un talk la
loro vita o che cosa avrebbero voluto
fare le loro idee che di quello che
avrebbero voluto fare nel futuro per
occorre parlarne
che cosa abbiamo abbiamo fatto quindi
con questo tipo di gestione del fenomeno
diciamo così in questi anni abbiamo
incrementato il traffico di esseri umani
se le persone non si possono spostare in
maniera legale lo faranno in maniera
lega illegale e ci sarà sempre qualcuno
passeur trafficanti mafie che vi aiuterà
in questo in questo viaggio tanto che il
traffico di esseri umani è diventato il
terzo al terzo posto per le mafie
internazionali per i traffici di tipo
illecito
il paradosso però di tutta questa
vicenda quale è che se samia e lei e
come lei tantissimi altri fossero
arrivati in europa avrebbero ottenuto
uno status di rifugiato avrebbero
ottenuto la protezione internazionale e
dei diritti che sono acquisiti che sono
libertà democratiche per tutti noi
il problema è che non ci possono
arrivare in maniera legale devono per
forza mettersi in mano a dei trafficanti
per poter esigere dei diritti che che
otterrebbero però non sono qua per
raccontare per fare lo spiegone sul
fenomeno immigrazione non ci sarebbe il
tempo ma per raccontare di
un'alternativa perché un'alternativa
esiste
un'alternativa e traffici di esseri
umani i traffici della morte i viaggi
della speranza
un'alternativa che non è solo un'idea io
so che it had normalmente si raccontano
idee in questo caso vorrei raccontare
anche una pratica perché ci abbiamo
provato l'abbiamo realizzato e siamo
partiti da il campi profughi abbiamo
attraversato quel confine di cui vi
dicevo prima siamo andati alle periferie
questi sono alcuni dei campi profughi
popolati da persone maya inizata ri
quella lì adattare in campo profughi in
giordania che ospita rifugiati siriani
gli champs elysée li chiamano i
rifugiati che che abita nella via
principale del campo da da in romagna il
campo profughi più grosso al mondo 500
mila persone
una città intera che abitano in kenya
ospitando cittadini somali e siamo
andati in quei quei paesi abbiamo
proposto un'alternativa di viaggi legali
che abbiamo chiamato corridoi umanitari
un'alternativa che che risponde a un
altro concetto di sicurezza
noi siamo abituati a ragionare di
sicurezza interna si parla sempre di
pacchetti sicurezza decreti sicurezza
bis tris e chissà quanti altri ancora
succederanno nel prossimo futuro però la
sicurezza non si costruisce per decreto
la sicurezza si costruisce praticando e
gestendo il fenomeno così come un altro
concetto di legalità le armi sono
illegali la droga e il legale le persone
non possono essere considerate illegali
viaggi non possono essere considerati
illegali allora abbiamo proposto
un'alternativa diversa mettendoci moto
come società civile anche finanziando
questo tipo di percorsi e se abbiamo
portato alcune immagini come queste di
viaggi normali
questi sono profughi tanto quanto gli
altri che arrivano con i barconi che
però scendono dagli aerei prendono
l'autobus arrivano agli aeroporti
esattamente come faremmo noi come
facciamo noi nei nostri nei nostri
viaggi e abbiamo cercato di contrapporre
agli slogan di chiusura degli degli
hashtag degli slogan di apertura apriamo
gli aeroporti perché è solo così che
riusciremo a fermare davvero il traffico
di esseri umani e devo dire che questa
esperienza perché modo né valsa la pena
questa è una bimba sia una biella
all'atterraggio a fiumicino con la sua
mamma in fuga da un paese con la
dittatura appena messo piede in italia
la sola ma mi è venuta ha sussurrato
finally freedom e ne valsa la pena anche
solo per sentire quelle due parole
finalmente libera questo significa che
l'europa e l'italia rappresentano ancora
per molti popoli al mondo una terra di
democrazia di libertà e chiudo
ritornando in etiopia da dove eravamo
partiti con quell'immagine iniziale ad
axum
questa è la cappella dove viene
custodita l'arca dell'alleanza o almeno
così si dice perché non la può vedere
nessuno tranne un monaco di clausura che
appunto di clausura che tende alla luce
accesa e sull'arca dell'alleanza in
qualche modo è staa proprio al di là a
pochi chilometri da quel fiume da cui
siamo da cui siamo partiti all'inizio
vicino nella zona nord vicino ai campi
profughi e in qualche modo penso che chi
oggi in europa è portatore di questi
valori costruttore di diritti umani
protettore di diritti umani un po come
quel monaco che tiene una luce accesa
non tanto sull'alleanza tra gli uomini e
dio così come l'arte dell'alleanza ma
tra gli uomini per custodire
quell'umanità che forse oggi stiamo ci
stiamo perdendo bombardati da una
pressione mediatica molto forte e che
potremmo ritrovare grazie
[Applauso]